[Music]
let's talk about the holidays uh any
great gifts anything that's uh stood out
anything that was fantastic that you
really liked or didn't like i had a nice
holiday and i had good gifts but um i
did get this really weird gift that coco
brought underneath the tree coco being
your daughter not team coco yeah okay
i'm a little self-focused uh
but she's here and she walked in and
she's like and she's a little celeb
because she was like is that for me oh
cause she sees team coco everywhere yeah
yeah that's what we do it's all for her
tell her i told her yeah so what did she
get you um well it wasn't she brought me
this present it was a big pillow that
and it's not from her and i couldn't see
who there was no tag but it said tonight
and then on the other side it said not
tonight
and first of all i'm like
well who
is going to be tonight
and why not tonight it's like it was so
confusing like who doesn't know me that
i'm gonna it's always why why is there
not tonight hey really
fantastic
david's also there with me and i'm like
this is so odd because
i don't know who to do it with tonight
another to not do it tomorrow night you
know what i'm saying yeah uh well
first of all let me reassure you there
are plenty of women that will use the
not tonight pillow i know but not when
you're in my
stage in life really
so you're just saying that you're always
uh interested in uh in like tonight
let's you're you're always in that state
of mind well
if you're in my bedroom i guess
i'm i guess do you understand
what the cable guy doesn't find out
about that
anybody that wanders into your bedroom
i don't think i'm being clear
i just didn't know who the person was
that i was saying not tonight to it was
a weird gift from someone i didn't know
yeah that's a weird gift from someone
you don't know that's like i was married
and yes yes you know but it didn't apply
so i thought well that's awkward i
should find out you should find out who
sent that i can't maybe this will help
yeah but i want to thank them yeah well
not now
what the hell does that mean thank you
uh we i want to ask you something this
is your we're on the wb lot warner
brothers lot and this is your old home
this is where you guys did friends yeah
stage 24.
is this
and i saw that the complete series just
came out like dvd blu-ray the whole
thing you haven't made enough money
a little more did you is that i mean do
you the show is in reruns everywhere do
you check the show out still do you when
you stop and watch it and reruns it's on
so often yeah i do like to i cuz i have
a really terrible memory
um so i love to watch because i never
know gosh i don't even remember that
episode or did we do that the only thing
that i and i love it it's so funny and
i'm so happy that i was
a part of this amazing thing but my
voice sounds so different because i
think they speed it up a little bit to
add one like they speed it up a few
frames to get another commercial in
there
and i if you don't know if you've ever
watched a rerun
you either found
minnie mouse
they can't speed up the show they do do
that they do yeah yeah they do
because i've noticed that with radio
shows too it seems like sometimes if
they replay someone's radio show
everyone's talking a little bit faster
you know and it seems like just so they
can make more commercial time yeah it's
true i think they do that those greedy
bastards
[Music]
it gives me an idea
you can make a ton of money